[Music]
copy
like i thought i saw smoke because he
was coming around that corner so it
shouldn't last too much longer
guys give me your speed
we're about 105 110 trying to catch up
there's still a little ways away it's
pretty good traffic still south of there
one's got it if you want to call it
10-3 10-3 someone just hit him into the
woods
car in the woods can't see the driver
all right everybody heads up he's trying
to drive the car out of the woods
all right guys we're going to get two
shields we're going to approach
trying to rock the car back and forth so
he's still inside
look
when they get a shield let's pin him in
y'all do not walk up on this car we got
enough
people up here
[Applause]
[Music]
okay we got units coming up just south
of dunlaw and it's the only vehicle
coming at you center lane blue lights on
only vehicle about three seconds out
[Music]
lieutenant shank i need to know if
there's any guns in that car that he
just stole
in the front
still northbound on 95 passing it on
long
traffic stopped on the on-ramp for
dunlop still no traffic northbound
center
[Music]
suv coco suv
in the shoulder right now
okay vehicle is smoking vehicle smoking
north of 95 or north of dunlop by about
a half mile
going into the inside lane
do you advise that's a swat officer's
vehicle
don't be in the same lane with him he's
going to lose debris all over the road
it's side lane he's starting to slow
down
about a
quarter mile south of williamson
overpass
you know i
north of the williamson overpass
all right he's breaking from the median
guys break it from the median breaking
for the median everybody slow down don't
ball up here
it's underneath the over the wires
underneath the wires in the median
on the ground
this is
sober up
can you come out here just want to talk
to you cassie
so
so
17 radio
cassie just came out of the back door
she she has my car
yes
i'm in front of her with boxer boxer
boxer boxer
she hit me she hit me
we got to stop
she's running she's running
[Music]
all right move over
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you